okay so this is the template for
evaluation we have the symptom up here
which is the effect cause evaluation is
basically connecting the symptom with
the correct real cause to do that you
have to evaluate which means to look
closely at all the information this is
data all the information that's what
you're asking questions you're narrowing
down your investigation so you have to
really study the subject if you're if
you're doing like for example if you're
let's say the adrenals okay
the adrenal body type you have to know
about the adrenal to be able to evaluate
because you if you have to know about
blood Sugar's to be able to evaluate you
have to know about a engine before you
can evaluate so this is an essential
like a thing you need to know first but
there's many many different causes of a
symptom and you're just going to narrow
down by asking questions and see what
aligns with a potential cause so like I
said if you have fatigue I mean that
could and you start asking like this is
the most important question time when
did it start when do you first notice
you've got a fever
when did you start nursing you started
getting late when did you start noticing
at a sleeping problem or fatigue then
it's going to be after a big clue and
then now that's going to start to narrow
down your thought process so we can rule
stuff out because let's say they have
pain in the right lower abdomen area and
then when did it start three days ago
and you thinking well it's probably
ovary and you're talking sound the phone
but then you find out when you ask a lot
of questions about the data you find
that this lady is 83 years old so what
does that tell you it tells you that
it's not going to be the ovary so what
happened when did it start happening
what happened just before what change
occurred with diet stress
what did you do she's she says I stopped
drinking the cranberry juice okay or or
not I'm sorry she started drinking at
cranberry juice
when this pain started okay in the lower
quadrant and you go okay well what could
now you know that what cranberry affects
the kidneys cranberry dissolves kidney
stones
so which he probably dissolved the most
obvious thing is she dissolve crud from
your kidney and it went down the tube
between your kidney and your bladder and
caused that discomfort so that would be
the most likely thing based on your
annoying information so you're looking
at the information you're asking
questions about it you're seeing how
things relate and you're just you say
like oh I don't understand that you keep
asking questions until you get to the
real cost okay that's the simplicity of
evaluation but again we have to link
cause and effect they're two different
things and when you get the right cause
you get a lot of cooperation from the
patient it makes sense to them they just
intuitively they go yeah okay that makes
sense depression let's take depression
for example so one of the things that I
want to add here is defining the problem
okay what do you mean by the depression
tell me what it feels like oh it's a
heaviness
it's a fatigue heaviness like oh okay
because what does depression feel like
what is anxiety feel say it anxiety I'd
say what does it describe it to me oh
it's like a heaviness where in my chest
ah or it's a I'm depressed I have
fatigue in my eyes I'm like oh well I
already know that tired eyes occur if
you skip protein for breakfast that's
just the fact that I know
and so the some of the questions I'm
going to find out what do you eat for
breakfast they're going to say I eat an
English muffin boom now we deal with now
it's a blood sugar thing you see how I
evaluated that
I'm associating data with a root cause
because I under understand the subject
quite well but if they say I have a
heaviness on my head and and you don't
get anywhere you say we'll have you ever
injured your head and they go yes I was
in the hospital for two months with a
head concussion I'm like oh my god
boom that's it right there so it's an
old injury I wonder your head and you
thought you depressed or you might say
fine they're depressed is really it's
it's really a tiredness in their whole
body and then you find out that they
don't sleep at all and then you find out
why keep asking questions you can find
the real cause but again that's how you
evaluate so you need to get good at
evaluation